''j'ai mardi phie de très nombreux
enseignants seront dans les rues et
notamment ceux de seine-saint-denis déjà
en grève depuis maintenant trois
semaines en grève contre la réforme de
l'éducation nationale ce matin ils ont
mené une action pédagogique pour
expliquer leurs revendications reportage
marianne buisson david fossard nathalie
pdci est juste une feinte saillard
d'orientation qui aime son métier pas
syndiqués peu habitué des manifs la
jeune femme est pourtant en grève depuis
trois semaines elle ne rate pas une ag
et le dimanche aussi il faut tracts et
ce matin c'est sur le marché on s'est
beaucoup de temps consacré à rédiger des
documents des tracts peut organiser des
actions pour pour faire savoir un petit
peu à tout le monde ce qui se passe ce
qui se passe c'est évidemment le projet
de décentralisation
les conseillers d'orientation sont en
première ligne alors en seine saint
denis ce sont eux qui ont lancé le
mouvement
les profs ont suivi puis les parents on
a commencé à fonctionner pas seulement
par établissement mais ensemble
voici une mobiliser les d'abord nos
enseignants nos collègues qui n'étaient
pas dans le mouvement
et puis ensuite chacun a essayé de faire
des réunions de parents et puis la sauce
prend ça fait trois semaines qu'on est
dans la bagarre on n'est pas du tout
découragés ce matin on était 25 sur le
marché 15 par an et dix ans et vient on
est très content bien sûr mardi tous
participeront à la journée de grève
générale
mais au blanc-mesnil le grand jour c'est
plutôt pour mercredi une grande réunion
publique à la bourse du travail
on y parlera orientation des élèves
disparition des médecins scolaires et
des assistantes sociales
les parents sont parties prenantes nous
on est interpellé parce que c'est vrai
que c'est que c'est une gêne dans notre
vie au quotidien pour les parents
enseignants d'aujourd'hui
école par école donc on s'enduit
smoothies et bien rencontre nous
essayons de comprendre les raisons ce
pourquoi en galice possibilité justement
de se mobiliser et d'agir ensemble
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire à ce que
c'est bien ce que c'est pas bien on est
là on en est là visiblement ce n'est pas
terminé
mille tracts distribués ce matin avant
d'autres ag d'autres rencontres et
peut-être manifestation le week-end
prochain